welcome to Table Talk where each week I
impact insights from Christian theology
and spirituality that help you become a
thoughtful contemplative in downright
great human being my name is Brett
pastor at the table and a few episodes
ago I talked about something that
neuroscientists call the default mode
network or the DM in for short so the DM
n is a collection of brain areas related
to processing emotions recalling
memories and thinking about what is to
come basically it's that or it's the
source of that endless stream of thought
that's constantly pouring forth from
your mind and here's the key the quieter
you are the less stimulated you are in
the world the louder it gets for example
and you simply go on a walk right you
just want to enjoy yourself so you go on
a walk and you have no music in your
ears or podcast nothing distract what
you'll quickly notice is that your mind
is not silent oh how you would long for
it to be but nope it's chattering away
at a million miles per hour don't forget
to grab the laundry remember little
Billy needs a soccer jersey what why did
your friend Rob look at you that way
this morning I think he has it he has it
in for you but maybe he hates you well
why was your mother so emotionally
distant when you were young I mean it's
absolutely endless
so I've hinted at this in past videos
but what I want to do in this video is
make very very clear that one reason I
believe the practice of silent prayer is
so powerful is because it's a process of
learning not not so much to fight the
dmn or make it your mortal enemy or get
angry at it but because it's a process
of learning to weaken the dmn by gently
returning to the presence of God in this
present moment flip IANS chapter 4 verse
6 puts it this way don't worry about
anything but pray about everything in
other words don't strengthen the dmn by
giving in to it by obsessing over things
by endlessly fruitlessly ruminating
about it instead return to God a hundred
thousand ten thousand times a day father
Thomas Keating is one of the great
contemplative Christians
of our time he was talking with someone
and they were very new to silent prayer
and they said uh father Keating my mind
is a mess
I'm trying to pray in silence for 20
minutes in the morning and 20 minutes in
the evening but I'm failing I mean my
mind is just going nuts and I don't
think I'm exaggerating when I say that I
become distracted 10,000 times per
session and you know what father Keating
said Oh 10,000 opportunities to return
to God yeah
what does Keaton's quote have to do with
the DM in a lot because the implication
is that the DM in is that voice in the
head that runyan commentary in the mind
that granted while useful from an
evolutionary standpoint I mean it kept
us alive when we were running from
saber-toothed Tigers it helped us avoid
danger it sort of kept us on our toes
but but in modern times it's like a
nuisance and honestly from a spiritual
perspective it prevents us from
connecting with God and so what do we
need to do we need to practice we need
to practice not feeding the dmn not
giving into it but simply acknowledging
it and then returning to that still
point within returning to Christ within
the Spirit of Christ within right that's
why I believe that a practice of prayer
is the most practical thing a person can
do I mean I think everyone should have a
prayer practice why because everyone has
a default mode network that is making
their lives miserable now if you'd like
a short overview of how to engage a
practice of silent prayer meditation you
can check out my last video but it
uploaded it's titled the secret that
taught me to pray so that's all for
today if you enjoyed this video please
like it share it with all your friends
comment and subscribe Grace and peace